walk me through now
your uh uh the moment where you and your
buddy lewis are sitting there and you're
saying what if we start our own company
called
you know uh jim shark and you know
how that led to you meeting steven 2015
kind of give me the history of how that
takes place takes place
so i said i loved it and i was really
really lucky
actually because in in growing up i saw
i grew up in
i still live here i grew up in a part of
the uk called the west midlands so we're
right in the middle
it's it's basically the industrial
powerhouse of of the uk
it's it's you know nowhere near as
wealthy as london it's just sort of a
very
it's a very i love it here but it's not
the wealthiest part of the uk
so we didn't have massive access to some
of the amazing software that's more
readily available today
now when i took this it class i didn't
know what it was at the time but it gave
me access to the adobe creative suite
and that's where you had dreamweaver so
you could make websites illustrator for
graphics photoshop and
i didn't realize at the time how lucky i
was to have access to this these
products but they literally completely
changed my life because
as a young creative all of a sudden i
could create the things that i was
imagining
in my head so started making all these
different websites
and iphone apps just because it was
something that i thought was cool
um and then after a while i wanted to
make a website that would transact
because everything else i've made didn't
actually sell anything
so i i had a friend who worked at a
supplement company at the time
and i said to him listen i want to make
a website that's going to transact i
need to know how much it's going to cost
me to buy some supplements off you
because
at the time i was massively into the gym
i was massively into fitness my dream
was to be like a
bodybuilder and um and he said to me
it's going to cost i think it was 8 000
pounds for a purchase of supplements to
sell on the website
now i'd never even heard of eight
thousand pound let alone seen eight
thousand pound at that point i was
working
uh i think it was like four pound eight
in out eighty an hour at pizza hut so
it was like it just was unfathomable for
me to be able to have that
so what we thought we would do is just
make a website that would transact and
then drop ship supplements
so for anyone that's watching that
doesn't know what drop shipping is it's
basically
you load the website up with a load of
product that you don't actually own
someone comes onto your website and buys
it and you basically ship it from
another vendor and it goes straight to
the consumer and you make a small margin
now the margin was tiny so i'll never
actually forget this we had our first
sale it took
three months i think to get the first
sale um
and it was a 50 pound supplement of
which two pounds was profit
now to any commercial business person
two pound profit
on a 50 quid sale is is not particularly
great and you have to do ridiculous
scale
for for that to be worth anything but
the aim of the game was just to be
involved in fitness any way that i could
and also build a website that would
transact and you know this did it so
i was like literally running around my
bedroom buzzing with the fact that we'd
actually made a website that transacted
so and that was how it started really
and it was
it was super organic right the the name
jim shark
because at the time i'd made so many
websites previously to me this was
another one i didn't know it would be
anything great so jim sharp was just a
cool domain that i found online it was
short
i bought it off godaddy it was about
three pound fifty
it was you know the whole startup cost
bearing in mind everything was drop
shipped and
and um our startup cost must have been
20 pounds thirty dollars you know it's
it's it's like nothing
so um yeah that's essentially how the
business started
what was your role and what did lewis do
was it was louis cmo
ceo ceo you were ceo cfo who who handled
what whose strengths
were what so at the time because it was
just it wasn't really
it wasn't like a business as such it was
just a case of let's go off and make
this so we didn't really have roles
now as we fast forward that's when the
business developed and roles sort of
occurred so
like i said we were drop shipping these
supplements and it was it was going okay
there'd be a sale every few days or so
because the margins were so small you'd
be making like
you know four or five pounds a week
maybe in terms of profits
so after a while and going back to sort
of look there was there was this
i guess something that was so fortunate
and lucky that just the stars had to
align
so in birmingham there's a place called
the nec which is the national exhibition
center
now every year they would have one of
the best fitness events in the world
called body power
and for me and all my friends that
wanted to be bodybuilders and basically
fitness people who just
followed that youtube scene massively
and the bodybuilding scene we'd check in
with olympia every year
that was like our one opportunity to see
these amazing people from around the
world normally from you know the us and
places like that
um so every year we would go to body
power just to be amongst the fitness
champions of the world and we were all
walking around
me and my mates and i'll never forget
this because i had to sort of run off to
pizza hut because my shifts would
normally start at five so we got there
saturday morning spent the day there
and you're looking at all these people
in all the fitness clothes and the
stringer vest and the more the old
school bodybuilding stuff
and then we try it on but because we
were more you know slender in our
physique than the huge bodybuilders it
would like
drown us because they would be so
massive so we just thought to ourselves
right why don't we just
try and make our own now conveniently at
the time my
nan was basically doing a curtain making
course
so i thought to myself why did we buy us
a sewing machine we bought a screen
printer
essentially with all of our savings and
we started to basically hand
make clothes to be honest more for
ourselves than anything else and then
happened to put them on the website
um i think that coincided with the fact
that we
loved youtube still do right so haven't
watched telly since
i was very very young that it would
always be around football or soccer in
the states
um i i literally just thought right
let's let's send
this product to that we love to some of
our heroes on youtube and see what they
think
and those guys started to wear it more
and more it you know built up
i guess a bit of a brand and people
started buying our clothes online
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]